the jurogan experience yeah
but there's also like gun culture that
people don't like the celebration
of shooting things and blowing things up
people get angry at that because they
feel like it's
glorifying it and they feel like you're
going to get those guns and put them in
the hands of
uh shitty toxic male people and they're
going to want to shoot people
if 400 million guns in this country if
we were a problem you would know it
yeah but it's really that simple it's an
old so many guns
right that's what's crazy and they think
about guns and people and
and yet and still we don't lead the
world
in gun deaths who does
that's a good question i think we
because we came in like we were like
right i think we're like at 12 number 12
or something like that really yeah
i thought we were number one no we're
not we need to work harder boys
we're number one no but even but even
but even still
again 65 of those are suicides right but
then if you were until i can hear people
say all the time
they'll say well those suicides are are
more efficiently done because of guns so
i was like so
what's the solution bans
make it harder no you just kill yourself
i mean
by banning guns yeah like i said but
like i said at the beginning of this
the only logical conclusion is to ban
guns what's up
the united states is low if you're going
per capita but that like
you take the top ten and you add them
all up and it's not as many as it
happened in the united states
so we're number one number two behind
brazil in terms of the actual like total
number
total deaths yeah total that's now
what's the population in brazil brazil's
got a lot of people
wow we're number one
uh number two by fourteen thousand
per hundred thousand we're number 25
20 which is which which i think is a
more accurate assessment if you take
into account the number of
what is the what's the population of
people in brazil so per capita we're
number 20
brazil has a lot of people go back to
the actual numbers again
what do we got there two all right on
that this is of twenty
so there's twenty 6 000 ish yeah
so 6 000 ish more in brazil
per year than the united states which is
uh that's surprising
but deaths per 100 000 they have 19 we
have 10. that's a big jump it's almost
double
i mean there's way more people in india
and they have way less yeah
way more people right they have like a
billion people yeah and then mexico is
surprisingly low
down there look at mexico that's really
low i'm kind of shocked by that
they have less than half of what we have
huh
interesting deaths per 100 hundred are
you talking are you talking about
population
no um the amount of deaths they have
total yeah from bones but what's the
population in mexico
well it says death per 100 000 they have
11.8 deaths we have 10.6
so wouldn't that make them more than us
there's a total
in terms in terms of per capita yeah per
capita but as far as as far as
total numbers look at venezuela 38.
oh yeah desperate hundred thousand they
have a lot more holy [ __ ]
they're number one el salvador's 39.
that's like 2500 people died i'm just
comparatively
still super dangerous 13 in greenland
yeah yeah but greenland has a population
of two people yeah they just killed each
other and they jumped up to number one
yeah it's um wow puerto rico is that
high on the list go back up to that
i'm gonna have to call john separately
it's part of america uh because it's not
the verb it is it is
not america it's like neither is hawaii
you know
i mean hawaii is america but let's be
honest
we stole that [ __ ] you know not we
but somebody did it's [ __ ] five hours by
plane in the middle of the ocean how the
[ __ ] is that america that's true and
it's kind of like all the cities in
houston
yeah this place i mean uh this uh this
chart is kind of surprising like seeing
those the the death numbers
that is surprising but so number one
all total deaths though is brazil so
we're number two
for all total deaths but brazil i don't
believe has the same population as
america was brazil's total population
i want to say 100 100 million rather
that's my guess 211.
211 and we have 300 million yeah
yeah brazil's dangerous as [ __ ] though
in some
some areas like the favelas you ever see
city of god yes
what a crazy movie that is in an eerily
way very beautiful at the same time yeah
yeah well it's a brilliant movie it's a
brilliant movie
yeah brazil's got a strange situation i
mean i think recently they
just think the new president just kind
of
loosened the grip on the gun laws in
brazil but generally speaking the gun
laws are very
very strict it is interesting that
places with the highest gun laws in
america
are the places with the most amount of
gun violence that's so strange
well i think i think because by and
large the
the attempted solution for the violence
because those places also have the
highest concentrations of inner cities
right and so their solution for those
for those things
was always gun control and in response
to it it's always more gun control and
if that doesn't work
add more gun control if that doesn't
work sprinkle a little bit more gun
control
and if that doesn't work let's put just
a little bit more gun control this time
i promise this gun control will work
and then it keeps happening gun control
gun control gun control gun control
that's the point that i'm making the
answer is always going to be gun control
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience